but going back to visual novels right
that we would recommend to beginners
aka not [ __ ] like one pain to another
okay other than other than doki doki
literature club what's like another
visual novel that you would recommend to
connor
oh no because there are none psych okay
question would you recommend karla shojo
because shoujo also has like act one is
it it takes it takes reading through act
one to get really invested into kind of
a shojo kind of show just great by the
way yeah
um but is that like a 10 million sabers
in that as well
there isn't there isn't 70 cuddlers
unfortunately
actually has a very very interesting
backstory
okay um because you saw me on it no
because i i mean
i feel like the backstory is almost as
interesting as the visual novel itself i
don't want to
say too much because i'm also working on
a visual
visual uh on a video on it but it's it's
it's a visual novel
that basically originated from 4chan and
can you believe something good actually
came out of force no no no
so it's like a dating simulator with
crippled girls
from 4chan and you say that and you're
like
i don't know about that i don't know
about the sjw's be quaking
yeah but like it's it's one of the most
like
wholesome kind of inspirational stories
about
how these disabled girls like really
just
are just normal people and just like
like how they deal with their
disabilities that sounds good yeah it's
great it's fantastic
it's it's a it's actually a really
really good visual novel and
if like how much patience do you have
though because i i i've seen you gaming
right
if you're not doing something within the
first five seconds if you're not like
head shotting
the headshot no scope
in the first 10 seconds i can't i have i
have a i have an amount that i can i can
like power up in myself but is it enough
to go through the first chapter of
cuddle ashoja why is it that bad
it's a it's a bit of a it's not bad it's
not it's a bit of a how long is the
first chapter
oh that's a good question i can't
remember
that's the same with doki doki because
like it takes an hour or two to get
through the first half
but mind you unlike doki doki which is
about a six to seven hour game cuddle
shojo is about 30 to 40 hours
that's fine so compared to that an hour
is not too bad until it starts
honestly i i do think sayonara would be
really really good for
someone some someone like you because i
know you can handle that [ __ ] and
that was something that hooked me
instantly maybe i'll stream am i a lot
of student is it a game i can stream no
it's banned on twitch oh geez
it was the first visual novel that was
banned on twitch because of course
you'd be out here just being like i'm
not making anything that's family
friendly
i'm here to traumatize everybody that
plays my [ __ ]
no because it it's it's a story it's
it's a vision novel that doesn't have
that you know entry period it just it
has a very interesting concept
and it just kind of hooks you right away
and for me i remember just reading
cyanusa and i read it all in like one
sitting because i just
wanted to know immediately what happens
next like there was there was no break
from me
starting it to finishing it um in terms
of like
visual novel type games i don't know
like
okay here's the thing do you would you
count the persona series as like a
visual novel
with a lot of gameplay in it well that
seems like an rpg to me
it okay the thing with the persona
series is that it's really interesting
because
yes it is a jrpg but a whole lot of the
jrpg
element and like how you play the jrpg
element of that game is dependent on the
visual novel side of the game yeah
because what what
what the persona series did which i
think is [ __ ] genius is that
they made you the way that they made you
sit through the story
of persona and it's a long story if you
played any persona game right yeah
the genius way that made you sit through
it is that by sitting through it and
physically interacting with certain
characters in certain ways
it changes how strong you become in the
jrpg element
yeah so what you do is you form at least
in persona 5
what you do is you you by talking to
certain characters and befriending them
and like going out to do these like
normal everyday things
yeah you would level up your different
abilities and those abilities then get
directly reflected in the jrpg element
so the more you're involved in the story
the easier time you will have in the
jrpg elements and what that forces you
to do is that not only is it interesting
because it's like
you're playing two different games at
once but you are literally forced to sit
through the story yeah yeah
so everybody who plays it enjoys the
story so like if you imagine like a
gacha game right
so in every gacha game there's like the
gameplay element and then there's the
gatch element well i played uh
fire emblem three houses right and that
had a lot of
story building which i found so boring
oh you found that boring yeah i found it
really boring but i would just skip
whenever they start talking i'm like bbb
but the thing is but the thing is fire
emblem three houses kind of did the same
thing where
you doing everyday things around the
campus would affect you in battle
i mean i liked fire emblem three houses
right i enjoyed
what i did but i i for
s whatever reason man the moment i see
text pop on my screen i'm like
i'm like you are in the way of my game
you are you are so monkey bro
you got that [ __ ] monkey